if you want to learn physics feynman
wrote the book uh just read the damn
book it's all there i really believe
that the connection to other humans on
any learning track becomes really really
really important i like to be on a team
i like ambitious goals i like thinking
through how we can anticipate the future
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person i'm not but when you
start your day off with a powerful
routine that inspires you for success
like watching one of these videos it
will change your life so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee know that i believe in you and
get ready for a shot of espresso from
bill gates
[Music]
the number of students who can learn
without a social setting around it is
very very small
uh you know if you want to learn
computer science
just you know knuth wrote the book buy
it okay
uh you know read it and do the problems
for if you really think you know this
thing if you want to learn physics
feynman wrote the book uh just read the
damn book it's all there so that when we
put stuff online
it we don't have anything in online
physics that's any better than feynman's
book honest honestly now it's a little
easier to learn uh you know the guy
makes jokes every 20 minutes or at least
tries to uh and he does more demos and
things so
learning is a weird social phenomena and
so you know our foundation our big
problem is that
the
group that does the worst with online
learning are low-income students because
their notion of why am i learning their
sense of self-confidence the ability to
figure out oh i just got stuck because
you know two minuses cancel out and i i
never saw that notation before they just
hit dead ends
all the time
that if you're sitting in your dorm at
stanford you know somebody walks down
and
helps you get through it
this clip is so powerful is so important
at least for me that i rewound it a
couple times emailed myself and wrote
down word for word what bill gates said
the first line of the clip was
the number of students who can learn
without a social setting around it is
very very small i think that is easy to
skip over
but i think it's really at the core of
why
people are not picking up the skills
they need to why you as an entrepreneur
you're probably not achieving what you
could because you don't have the social
setting around it and it's very powerful
for me let's go in this little side
story because
i want to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves i want to teach people how to
believe in themselves more and i think
that little aspect there of the social
dynamic and social structure
is really important
when i started movement makers
where i train thought leaders and
entrepreneurs how to get their message
out you got a big message inside you i
want to see it get out to the world
at the beginning
it was just me presenting
it was me taking 85 minutes
every two weeks you guys pick a topic
people voted in facebook what they
wanted me to talk about and i would talk
about it for 85 minutes
i started to see such amazing
connections between people that i
realized
i don't want to be the go between
because it's limiting because i have to
know what everybody's up to and where
they're from and what they're trying to
do and as we've grown movement makers i
can't know what everybody's exactly
working on right now
so we created breakout sessions where
you get to meet other people in the room
and as an introvert and someone who's
shy that is that sounds terrifying to me
i hate the idea of breakout rooms i'm
going to be put in a room of people that
i don't know who they are and be be
asked to talk about something
even just thinking about it
terrifies me
and so the fact that i would do that to
the people you know who who pay me to be
part of their program
uh makes me worried that i'll disappoint
them
but it ended up being
one of the greatest things
that we do
because the more you can feel like
you're connected to other people that
you're learning together that you're not
on this journey alone
the more likely you are to actually
follow through
that community aspect that we built in
that just felt intuitively right from
the feedback that we were getting i
think is actually
a cornerstone for how people should lead
any kind of education or training
you could think about that for your own
training for you as a human like how do
you stay consistent on something well if
you're doing it with somebody else
you're way more likely to follow through
or think about it for the training that
you're leading is there a way to make it
a community vibe so that other people
are connected to each other and they'll
be more likely to follow through
we are probably the most
optimistic positive people that we know
right if you're watching this video you
care about your self-growth you've been
on a journey you've come through some
pretty hard things and you're here now
and you're still standing and you're
ready to go and build something bigger
for yourself right that's why you're
here believe nation come on let's go
that's why we watch these videos we're
trying to grow learn improve get better
and you're probably the most positive
person that you know and that's amazing
and you're pouring into other people
and yet there's nobody doing that for
you
people are coming to you for advice and
wisdom and guidance and support and an
ear
to you know listen to their problems but
who's doing that for you and i think
that's one of the big reasons why most
people don't follow through and i've
i've defaulted i'm thinking out loud
here as i go on this video is a lot of
personal reflection on that one comment
i've defaulted to environment which i
think is super important with videos
like this
with books and podcasts and i genuinely
believe that if you watch one of these
videos every day it will shift your
mindset forward it will shift your
learning forward even though you may
never meet me you may never meet bill
gates you may never meet these people
you're still hanging around them and
you're still learning and they're
pulling you towards success if you watch
a video from some of your heroes every
single day
you may not notice a shift on a
day-to-day basis but you look back weeks
months even years later and say wow i've
i think differently i have more
confidence i have more courage i have
more self belief you still aren't going
to be where you want to be
and news flash you always want growth so
you never want to be stuck where you are
you always want growth that's that's
part of the human condition that's
amazing
and you've come a long way from where
you used to be and so i think the
environment really plays a part of that
and i really believe that the connection
to other humans on any learning track
becomes really really really important
and i'm honestly trying to figure out
how could i do that more
with the youtube community with you guys
you know inside movie makers it's it's
pretty solid you get introduced to other
people in the group even before you join
the first meeting you're probably going
to be connected to somebody else in the
group to have a conversation inside the
group where it's a dance party at the
beginning you're meeting people uh
you're going to be put into breakout
rooms you're learning together we have
challenges that we do there's a lot of
interconnectivity and i think
that's probably one of the biggest
reasons why people stick is they get to
meet other people who are like them if
you feel like you're a weird duck and
nobody else around you is like you well
now you get to be in a room with people
who are like you and automatically even
if the
even if the topic of the day isn't
as relevant or valuable to you and what
you're facing right now just being
around other achievers other optimistic
bright positive people makes a
difference will change how you show up
for the rest of your day week month etc
but i don't know how to do it yet on the
youtube side of things i don't know how
to help you guys as much beyond
hey i always say leave a comment below
tell me how you're going to apply the
lessons in this video encourage each
other
it really just makes me think
what else could we do to make the
learning
more community
guided more community focused because at
the end of the day
if i really want to solve the world's
biggest problem you know people don't
believe themselves enough
the more we could put the world
on a believe
curriculum together and create that
community
i think we'll get a lot more results
i think i think we've all
felt
the
challenge and hurdle and struggle of
trying to do everything on our own
i look at my own career my own journey
every time i tried to do something by
myself i always struggled but whenever i
had a model to follow
or a mentor to guide me i did better
and i think as we
continue on this journey together
hopefully you've grown a lot if you're
still you know watching this video and
subscribe to this channel i appreciate
you
and definitely open to ideas on how to
make it even more
community guided community focused how
do we put the world on a belief
curriculum that we could do together
it's some good food for thought
most of the time when i'm doing the
videos here
i'm
sharing my thoughts and giving you
challenges this one is a different vibe
this one is is uh
challenging me to think as well which is
why i love this content right if i
didn't have this channel i wouldn't have
been exposed to this video would have
made me think and have this moment with
you guys here today so
instead of our usual question of the day
i'd love to know your thoughts how do we
spread more belief how do we make the
community even stronger how do we get
everybody on a on a belief training
curriculum so that you feel like you're
not alone
every day and trying to show up and
chase down your dreams any feedback
suggestions comments hot takes i'd love
to see them down in the comments below
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief the sign
says it can take up to
254 days of consecutive action for the
habit to stick that's what i want for
you so i've designed a custom free
program where i'm going to send you an
unlisted video for the next 254 days to
shift your confidence and belief forward
the link to join is in the description
below you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream a lot
of people are going to get out there and
use it when you have the level of
success that we've had when you have a
business that's important as this with
this many competitors you're going to
have people saying some nasty things if
you ask people across the united states
is the future going to be better than
the past
most say no
you know you can over
worship and mythologize the idea of
working extremely hard
for my particular makeup
i mean it really is true that i didn't
believe in weekends i didn't believe in
vacations i mean you know i knew
everybody's license plate so i could
tell you over the last month when their
car had come and gone from the parking
lot is so i don't recommend it eh
i don't think most people would enjoy it
once i got into my 30s i could hardly
even imagine how i had done that
because by then some natural behavior
kicked in and i loved weekends and
you know my girlfriend liked vacations
and that turned out to be kind of a neat
thing
now i take lots of vacations
my 20-year-old self is so disgusted with
my uh current uh
self you know i i was sure i would never
do anything riding coach you know now i
have a plane so it's it's
very much counter revelations have taken
place at high speed
but yes it is nice
if during those first several years
if you have a team that's chosen to be
pretty
maniacal about the company and how far
that goes you should have a mutual
understanding so you're not
one person expecting one thing another
person to expect another thing
and you'll have individuals who
who have you know health or relatives or
things that are distracted but yes i
have a fairly hardcore view
that there should be a very large
uh
sacrifice made during those
those early years today people come to
you all the time for money i assume
everywhere you go people say by the way
i have this thing you should invest in
but i have a couple of myself i'll
mention later no no
no a couple things you should invest in
or things you give money to so how do
you resist do you have some person who
says no for you
or how do you do that
let many people uh many people say no
well once you picked what you care about
if somebody has something that can make
a difference in global health we're
super interested and you know we have
staff of 1500 people and if it's to do
with global health some of those people
will come out and talk through with you
whatever your innovation is and how we
can partner with you on that you know so
that's clearly in our area if it is
something that can substantially improve
k-12 education then we're going to be
very interested in it if people are
asking outside of those things then you
know fortunately you can say no because
focus is is key to philanthropy the
digital
revolution internet social media all of
that in certain respects it's made it
easier for us to see what's going on
medical researchers are publishing
articles every day and all over the
world people can immediately see what
the new thinking is there tracking the
disease statistics i click on the john
hopkins website every morning and see
okay which countries are having a tough
time with cases or deaths thank god for
the internet work at home you know our
ability to connect up with each other is
driven by that but it also has meant
that a lot of very surprisingly
interesting conspiracy theories that are
false sadly they spread a lot faster
than the truth you know so the idea that
did somebody intentionally cause this
thing completely false even in some
cases accusing me of having some
connection
that can be dangerous because it means
you know your willingness to believe is
the vaccine something i should take
should i wear masks you know if you go
for these simple but wrong theories
getting people to work together and
protect each other so we can get out of
this as soon as possible that's really
at risk
you raise the question of how should the
government deal with that it's very
difficult ideally citizens are just well
informed and they know which
publications are very careful about what
they say and we don't have to engage in
censorship but so much of the almost
crazy false information is out there
that looking at the companies like
facebook and saying okay what is their
role in that you know when somebody says
masks don't work which is wrong or they
say just take
hydroxychloroquine and you'll be totally
safe what is their responsibility for
catching those things particularly get
out to large numbers that is being
debated and you know i think we'll come
out of this with those companies feeling
a stronger sense of responsibility and
actually understanding having the public
debate about uh how they need to help
here you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream a lot
of people are going to get out there and
use it and that they're going to be
willing to pay for some content is that
the operating idea that you have
well each of these businesses
is an entrepreneurial business
the overreaching theme is that yes i
believe in the internet i believe it'll
get increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that is you've got a lot of cash on
hand yes
right all right
it puts you in an envelope position you
can experiment with a lot of
entrepreneurial ideas and see what
sticks and what flies
well we're in business to make money and
but the other thing is providing such a
cash flow for you
well it all belongs to the shareholders
that we're not dilating no i know we are
business people and it is true that if
you find an idea
that requires three or four years of
improvement and patience and really
sticking with it uh that we're very good
at that take windows which we bet our
company on everybody who doubted that
would succeed ibm did not support us in
that
it took longer than we expected
over four years before finally graphical
interface got popular and now people
take it for granted it's part of every
personal computer and you just you just
expect it to be there that was one of
the grand successes of the company in
the same way we're betting on the
internet that our tools there will be
popular and that a few of these content
plays that we've decided to get involved
in that the scale and and the users will
make those into great businesses we also
are big believers in in united way and
and what goes on there and that's more
at a business level we sort of think
every business ought to do that it's a
basic thing because social services
we think have a a deserve particular
priority
in terms of drawing employees in to
to help help the community and there's
ways to take those fundraising things
within a company and have contests and
comparisons and great stories get the
word out make it fun make it easy you
know it's just a piece of email the
easiest thing to do is click and say you
want to give your fair share and then we
send you no more email uh so we've
made it the easiest thing to do is is
is
participate in terms of individuals it's
quite different
you know you can take and give to groups
like united way who are really thinking
about everything in the community or you
can find things and most people mix this
you can find things that you're
particularly interested in that you know
about that a relative benefited from or
that you want to go and volunteer
in
uh you know microsoft does the thing now
for every hour that somebody volunteers
we actually
uh make a grant to that organization
because that says that there they care
about it and uh they think it's it's
doing very good work
now for individuals at some levels
probably most you're giving is going to
be
in the community where you know what's
going on
i'm a big believer that
that the some of the greatest inequities
are on a global basis
and so uh one of the things our
foundation tries to get out is the names
of a number of organizations like save
the children or global fund or vaccine
fund that we know
are taking dollars in a very efficient
way and saving lives and improving
conditions and you know i would hope
that as people
are able to be fairly generous that this
international component that it be part
of of what they're doing
obviously if you get up to enough scale
then you can
take on big projects and i will get a
chance with some of my extra time to go
out and and share with people who are
uh
lucky enough to have wealth and just
tell them how much fun i'm having and
that can have impact and hopefully
encourage it i i think when warren
buffett gave his gift it sent a message
to people that wow
uh
we got
this is the the right thing to do and
you know he he doesn't like to waste
money
uh so you know a sense that there are
causes out there
that you can make a big difference with
there's no doubt
that
uh you know creating a board
having people like dave marquart there
who
wasn't at the company you know and we
were so overwrought about you know this
is right this is wrong we messed this up
that having people have a little bit of
distance uh come in and talk to us is
good you know for the last
uh
oh 30 years or so
i've gotten to be friends with warren
buffett and he he's in omaha
he's not in this tech world at all you
know and to him it's like hey how could
you ever know which will rise and which
will fall i'm not going to put money uh
until
apple sold at a multiple of 12. then
he decided he could put 50 billion into
that
[Laughter]
after he asked all his friends hey you
know if the if somebody had an uh iphone
that was half as expensive would you
switch away you know or is it more like
jewelry where you really want
to to have an iphone and so he decided
that the those profit streams might not
be
eliminated anytime soon anyway he
because he's not in
this world
he has a a definite
way of looking at things including this
idea of how
work should be fun he has made his work
so much fun
that
he works more hours than i do he works
six days a week at 88 years old and he
likes to say that he skips to work every
day he he doesn't but
he says that
when he was 83 he could still skip but
now he's done
really he can't do it so
having somebody like that you know the
toughest thing i went through was this
anti-trust lawsuit where
you know it didn't seem
very predictable
and he was a great counsel
during all of that stuff so getting
somebody who's in successful in another
domain
but yet kind of a business
type
mindset anyway for me that that was a
huge gift i think
it's important that we build that
feedback system now exactly how you do
that how much you connect that up to the
pay system uh you know we need
experimentation and we can look at these
other countries that have done it there
is a move afoot to do some of this but
whether the investment levels be enough
to make it high quality and whether the
um
there'll be kind of high stakes that
overuse the test scores
for this stuff and and will sort of hurt
its reputation it's hard to say at this
point but i'd say it's
giving more feedback to teachers would
be the very first thing
that would get us
back up to the uh to being one of the
best in the world if you want to have
impact uh
usually delegation's important um
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started i wrote most the code
and everybody else's code i read and
kind of rewrote uh
and
that got us up to 10 people and then i
had to say to myself okay we're going to
ship code that i didn't edit uh
and that was hard for me uh but you know
i kind of got over that then i still
said okay i'm gonna interview everyone
and i'm gonna at least look at samples
of their code well that got us up to
about 40 people
and that was at a point where
i had sold way more software than we
could write uh because everybody was so
impressed
and i thought well i need to keep enough
collect enough money to you know keep
hiring all these people
but uh the demand was so high that you
know we were actually falling behind
that's when i hired steve
and steve figured out a
uh how to control what promises i made
to people uh and b how to hire lots of
people and good really good people and
create organizations and teams so i
delegated to steve that and he was
constantly saying to me okay we're gonna
hire programmers that you've never met
and i'd say no or not and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't going to work uh you
know so uh then i said okay then i would
you know know all the managers of the
people and so over time
uh and of course
you know i could say the quality per
person was falling monotonically
according to me
but you know large problems
uh if you want to you know write the
most popular
office productivity software that one
person absolutely can't do that you can
write pretty code so everyone has to
decide what scale of organization they
want to work in eventually you know my
role was very much as a leader and a
reviewer of managers but the top people
and i hired some super experienced
people
uh i would make sure they were pursuing
a common vision and they were well
coordinated but in terms of a lot of
management stuff they were way better
than i was now i had to have the
framework to know what mix of skills
that we needed and you know when they
were working well enough together but a
lot of uh
you know my
value-added was picking
say to do graphics user interface or to
do an integrated office
type thing or to go global and not use
agents to have microsoft be present all
over the world
and
so yeah picking what you're good at and
how you find the other people uh to fill
in those things that's super important
and most founders don't aren't able to
scale that up and kind of give up
the hands-on things that they used to
get a lot of
uh pleasure and comfort from urgency
that i felt
that if we didn't get microsoft going
right away that somebody uh would do a
great job building a software company we
won't have a chance that probably ended
up not being true that i could have
waited two or three years and the
opportunity to do microsoft still would
be there but anyway i felt a sense of
urgency uh and
you know it's not like
you know i still get to take courses and
learn things um today you know things
like the learning company and there's
all sorts of great books so it's not
like i've missed some part of my
education when you dropped out your
father and mother said are you sure you
know what you want to do if one of your
children dropped out of college to start
a company what would you say
well i'd have to say yes but uh
the dropping out is not an irrevocable
decision uh
you know if you try and start a company
it doesn't go well they always let you
go back
uh
and so if you don't have
you know kids that you need to uh
support you know it's a very low risk
thing particularly in the culture of the
united states where trying to start
something and and failing is not a black
mark for the rest of your life when you
were starting microsoft there were a lot
of other software companies and you were
not number one at the beginning i think
there were mothers who were a little bit
further ahead what was it that enabled
you to beat everybody else up in the
software business was it bill gates was
it something else what was the unique
factor that made you the most successful
yeah we were actually the first and but
there were companies
and they were all kind of single product
companies
who got ahead of us
in terms of sales
you know by
about 1991
we
did become the largest
uh of all of them we were an engineering
company we were about
how you hire smart people and how you
use tools to develop software broadly
we were global
and we weren't about a single product so
like for example word perfect was a word
processor somebody might remember
they did so well with that product that
their gross sales
rivaled ours when we were doing a broad
set of products as soon as graphics
interface caught on which was windows uh
that became mainstream in 1995 we became
far larger than the other software
companies now subsequently
uh you know google
apple
uh amazon have become
uh
you know also extremely successful but
in the 90s we were
the strongest uh okay by far there's no
doubt that the antitrust lawsuit was bad
for microsoft and
it
we would have been more focused on
creating the uh
phone operating system and so instead of
using android today you would be using
windows mobile if it hadn't been for the
honor trust case uh microsoft would go
oh we were so close we we you know i was
just too distracted i screwed that up
because of the distraction and you know
we were just three months too late with
the release that motorola would have
used on a phone uh
so yes uh it's a winner take all game
that is for sure that you know now
nobody here's ever heard of windows
mobile uh but oh well
and i wouldn't uh
that's a few hundred billion here or
there
i wouldn't have retired as soon and that
one is less you know i am disappointed
that windows mobile didn't succeed but
in terms of
uh my own life
you know even though it was a very
painful thing because i got very
personally involved in the defense of
the company the fact that i retired
earlier probably net was good for me
because i got down the learning curve on
the foundation i got to partner with
melinda in the early days of the
foundation
and you know i don't have a life where
i'm allowed to complain uh because
basically you know only 99 of things
have worked out very very well the
idea that you could get people to
to decide to support this foreign aid
thing which is a big deal
for our foundation from a numeric point
of view we're still pushing that a
little bit but honestly the story of the
one child
you know if you say to an audience
here's the picture of the child shall we
save this child
they're more engaged than if you said
hey let's save a million children you
know so there's definitely a sort of you
know 10 to the sixth problem uh here
somewhere
that humans are not wired
uh
to be
to do that on a numeric basis um and so
you know that's why we have people like
bono and and many others who come from a
more storytelling world and then they
let me throw a few charts and numbers in
because i think uh that that should
should be there once your heart tells
you what direction to go in to prove
that this is a a very affordable
not you know not a big deal well-managed
path to to be on if you were
20 years old today and you wanted to
start a new company drop out of harvard
what company or what area would you want
to start it in
well this is a
great time to be doing innovation
because the tools of innovation are so
much better
there are lots of things in biology that
are very interesting uh
there are lots of things in energy that
are interesting given my background i
would start an ai company
that
whose goal would be to
teach computers how to read so that they
can absorb and understand
all the written knowledge of the world
that's an area where ai has yet to make
progress and it will be quite profound
when we achieve that goal most people
over the last 200 years or so whoever
the the wealthiest person in the world
was didn't usually work that hard when
they got to be 60 or so they kind of
took life easy you seem to be working
pretty hard what motivates you to still
work so hard
well i love my work the work of the
foundation is super interesting i get to
meet with the scientists i get to go out
in the field i do think your habits are
sort of set in your 20s and 30s
and by my standards of the 20s well you
know i didn't believe in weekends back
then uh not to mention vacations so i'm
you know fairly lazy compared to myself
in my 20s where i was a true uh fanatic
uh you know all i believed in was
working on software
night and day and and for my 20s that
was perfect i didn't have a wife or
family uh
at all and my rule was very
hands-on role you know i i'm very lucky
that my foundation work the part-time
work i do for microsoft i see that
extending you know for decades
into the future and having an
understanding of innovation uh you know
i think shaping innovation in many of
these areas
uh there is a unique role that i can
i can help play i like to look at
numbers a lot and so when i look at the
numbers i'm just amazed whether it's the
quality of the inner city education the
dropout rates oprah did a thing where
she had kids from intercity school go
look at the suburban school and vice
versa and they were just stunned that
the building and everything was so
completely different so i think you know
even for me i have to go you know
whether it's the inner city in america
talking to people who live there or
outside the us we have this same thing
you know the situation in africa you
know it's overwhelmingly uh black
population is so much worse than people
are probably aware of and so hands-on
visits whether it's to the schools or
the clinics i think that is necessary to
hear the voices of people who've been
hurt and then you know there's a lot of
good movies now there's a lot of good
books i was just reading the new jim
crow which is pretty eloquent and
forceful about the justice system and
the role that it plays in perpetuating
bad conditions and
you know it takes a lot to try and put
yourself having empathy for other people
so we all have to push harder on this i
get to when i
you know say okay we're going to build a
tb drug team we're going to build the tb
vaccine team we're going to build them
you know kill all the mosquitoes in the
world gene drive crispr team
i get to
in terms of how we fund that organize it
how many locations do we wait till they
have this result before we scale it up i
get to use the same
uh
or 80 percent the same
type of thinking that i exercised in
terms of
okay let's go do windows let's go do
excel
so it's backing engineers it's getting a
sense of the team you know what needs to
be added to that team or the iqs on the
team adding up uh as opposed to
subtracting from each other and it's
very comfortable because
the the most intense period of microsoft
was where these teams were about size 30
and for our diseases
you know typhoid rotavirus there's a lot
of diseases uh
that hopefully you'll never hear of
again uh most of which don't exist here
in the us but uh
so it is very very similar it takes a
decade generally from start to finish
the aids vaccine actually we're on year
14 and
it'll probably be another eight to ten
years before that one is completely done
so some take as long as
as 20 years
because there's many dead ends and you
have kind of a portfolio of approaches
but yes i feel like my working with
governments hiring smart people
uh managing teams it did prepare me well
for this very operational
uh organization
that's a lot like a business except that
we're
our profit is live saved
as opposed to a monetary
measure certainly during the time i was
at harvard
i wasn't sure what i was going to do uh
the idea that software was this field
that uh
was the opportunity was
unbelievable that became more obvious
during the three-year period i was here
uh but my dad had been a lawyer
i thought of mathematics you know like
doing well in the putnam that was the
coolest thing uh and the computer
software
i didn't think those people were as
smart as the math people so it's like
well am i gonna go into the easy field
or this really hard field but
anyway math uh was fantastic when i
finally picked
and decided to go do microsoft then i
got into a period
from age
19
to about
40 where i wasn't able to
look at the latest on you know how
tornadoes work or how mitochondria work
i was pretty mono maniacal
and when i was able to ask steve this is
the year 2000 c balmer
uh he he mistakenly graduated uh but
then he started it stan
but i was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine but then he
started at stanford business school and
he was in his first year and i thought
this is perfect i'll get him to drop out
of stanford business school uh so in a
certain sense he is a dropout uh
uh and he was very key to the success of
microsoft i mean uh he knew a lot of
things but during that period i didn't
get to do much at harvard
you know i took all these courses
because it was just so amazing that
people were interested in talking about
them and
i i have to say i never went to a
lecture during reading period or any
anything because the courses that i was
actually signed up for i finally started
to work on those so i was in halel the
minute would open to the minute we
closed during reading period trying to
catch up on on that other set of courses
so people say i'm a dropout which is
literally true
but
because i like college courses the
online college courses there's a company
called the learning company that i buy
uh tons and tons of their stuff and i do
in at least four or five courses a year
in a sense i like
uh going to college more than anyone uh
so
i've sort of made sure my job certainly
post microsoft
uh that i get to spend my time meeting
with scientists
learning new things you know seeing what
the hard problems are
in some cases giving money to people to
take on
uh
those very very hard problems i decided
to to focus more on uh giving away than
than making money
and so i've uh gotten a chance to travel
the world be out in africa and asia
quite a bit and see the needs that are
out there and now our foundation is very
focused on global health
focused on agriculture because the
majority of the the very poor in the
world are farmers who have very small
plots of land so any increase in
productivity or certainty of their crop
coming in
can make huge difference for them
and you might think of a career in
software
you know selling to uh people who can
afford personal computers and now
uh the career at the foundation is being
very different and certainly they're
different in the sense that now it's
about vaccines now a lot it's it's with
various uh governments uh the donor
governments the governments and import
countries but at its core it's really
basically the same thing which is
uh finding innovators people who've got
breakthrough ideas
be willing to back them understand what
they're working on
measure
what they're coming up with
try and make sure that when it's
delivered it really has the impact it's
supposed to be in getting into a
feedback loop driven by
a very precise measurement first i met
warren we were talking about getting
together and doing uh something again
and he pulled out his calendar
and the pages were so blank
and i said wow you know you've managed
to avoid getting tied into a lot of kind
of meaningless activity
and you know warren said yeah you have
to be good at saying no uh and picking
the things that that really make a
difference and that's one of many things
i've learned from warren but that's one
of my favorites and uh so i can blame it
on him whenever i'm turning things down
the nice thing now that i'm
not uh so extreme in my 20s i i didn't
get to read uh much at all and so like
all this stuff is going on in biology
and math
i just didn't didn't get to read it then
when i did get into my 30s those
vacations were
a time to go back uh because when i was
a student you know you could study
all sorts of things uh
anyway um
now
you know i read a lot of science uh and
that uses up uh you know maybe half of
the slots uh
that that i have really understanding
u.s poverty and what's going on there
there's a a few dozen books that try and
give you a glimpse of that that are very
good this book facts on this let me say
you know it definitely uh
creates a framing
uh
for what's going on in the world and the
other one that's right up there is any
uh pinker book
starting with uh
better angels of our nature i think
success is always a bit dangerous
you know and you can think that whatever
your success was was because
you know you are magically
uh
gifted and understanding things whereas
of course any success particularly a
gigantic success is a huge number of
factors including hard work and
understanding but
timing you know other people who came to
work with you other people who might
have done the same thing who somehow
messed up uh in doing it
and so often you'll
you'll have too much confidence about
what you understand
uh you know in science uh as feynman
said the easiest person to fool is
yourself
uh and so you have to force yourself to
go through
uh you know again and again and think
through is this the right thing to be
doing you know will this work am i doing
it because it would be exciting if it
succeeded am i really looking at these
factors in fact in polio several times
we had to say to ourselves was it time
to give up uh
or really did we think there was a
prospect of
being able to move forward you have any
regrets in your life you seem to have a
life that many people would love to live
you got a happy family great marriage
foundation business success is there
anything can you make us feel good by
saying you've done something that didn't
work out or just make us because all of
us feel bad because we look at you and
we can't do what you've done so tell us
something that's bad that you've done or
you'd feel inadequate about something it
must be something i am super lucky uh
you know they
marrying melinda
uh
the experience at microsoft uh that
although it had its ups and downs was uh
phenomenal
uh the work of the
foundation and
no regrets about anything i wouldn't try
and go back and change anything i mean
for example
the
antitrust lawsuit against microsoft you
know was bad for the company it created
a lot of distraction we would have done
a lot of things including the mobile
operating system better if it hadn't
been for that but in a way it was a
lesson for me
uh
and
you know so it and it probably
accelerated my retirement uh by five or
six years which overall for me probably
was a a good thing
um you know i don't think it was a
principled set of activities but that's
another story so today the greatest
pleasure of your life is when you're
doing what is it other than being
interviewed by me or something like that
what are the great greatest pleasure of
your life
uh you know time with
kids
time with scientists uh time when i'm
reading and things are making sense
um
you know going out and seeing the impact
of the foundation's work
uh
meeting with scientists who think we can
make breakthroughs to
help solve climate uh you know these are
super
interesting problems
and
you know having a broad set of system
thinking applied to these problems
is going to be necessary
to orchestrate the resources and
policies behind them so you know i love
i love my work the key thing was that
paul allen and i
had loved working on software since we
were lucky enough to be exposed
literally i was 13 in eighth grade when
this time sharing terminal came in and
we just did it day and night and you
know got better and we could see
that the magic of software combined with
this miracle of the microprocessor
subject to moore's law exponential
improvement that that was a magic
combination and we we'd look around and
say hey how come everybody's not
saying this is amazing i mean we're
going to dethrone ibm and uh you know
why doesn't digital equipment get it why
is the guy who runs it this is a company
that's long gone
but dominated many computers at the time
why isn't that guy up there saying it's
it's wrong we know it's right
and so the key event for us was it was a
very cold boston winter
and a kid computer came out on uh this
popular electronics magazine
and we said oh damn this is happening
without us i mean here we are
uh
doing nothing
and so we called the company up and said
you know hey we're ready uh and then we
called them back we actually did the
work and then we called them back and
said how do you make the stuff go in and
out of the computer the i o
and they said well that's interesting
nobody else has ever asked that you must
really be doing something so that was
anyway our very first customer and so we
grabbed on to it to be the very first
and we were the first to say there
should be a software industry
and come and do it in a sense it was one
of the lower risk things i've ever done
in my life because
you know i could have always gone back
uh you know what my parents my dad
didn't say hey
if you
go away for a few years i'll stop paying
for education they were nice and said
okay go
you know learn your lesson down there in
the desert and uh
and you get back to the serious stuff
and you know we're still we're still
waiting if you want to learn computer
science just you know knuth wrote the
book buy it okay
uh you know read it and do the problems
for if you really think you know this
thing if you want to learn physics
feynman wrote the book uh just read the
damn book it's all there so that when we
put stuff online
it we don't have anything in online
physics that's any better than feynman's
book honest honestly now it's a little
easier to learn uh you know the guy
makes jokes every 20 minutes or at least
tries to
and he does more demos and things so
learning is a weird social phenomena and
so you know our foundation our big
problem is that
the
group that does the worst with online
learning are low-income students because
their notion of why am i learning their
sense of self-confidence the ability to
figure out oh i just got stuck because
you know two minuses cancel out and i i
never saw that notation before they just
hit dead ends
all the time
that if you're sitting in your dorm at
stanford you know somebody walks down
and
uh helps you get through it i feel like
you always
seem to swing for the fences in general
it's just sort of a new way of framing
it but i have to ask if you are swinging
for the fences
what if you miss well hopefully uh you
get more than one swing okay
uh either at the same problem like you
know multiple malaria vaccine constructs
so that you know if you have two or
three the combined chance of success is
much higher or
that you're working in multiple areas
not just one area right you know in
climate for example
i have a company that's uh trying to
make a nuclear reactor
that would be very cheap and that would
have safety so that the public
would be very accepting of it now
you know even i realize that's high risk
you know less than 50 chance all that
comes together and yet uh
if it did
and the only reason i'm involved is it
would really help with climate uh let us
generate electricity without any
greenhouse gases when i started
microsoft
i didn't think of it as all that risky i
mean i was so excited about what we were
doing it's true i could have gone
bankrupt uh but
you know i had a set of skills that were
highly employable and in fact my parents
were still willing to let me go back to
harvard and finish my education if i
wanted to you've always got a job with
bayville
and
the only the thing that was scary to me
wasn't quitting and starting the company
it was when i started hiring my friends
and they expected to be paid
and then we had customers who went
bankrupt customers that i counted on to
come through and so then i got this
incredibly conservative approach that i
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay a year's worth of payroll
uh even if we didn't get any any
payments coming in
and you know i'm almost
true to that the whole time we have
about 10 billion now which is is pretty
much enough for the next year
anyway
you know i
if you're gonna start a company it takes
so much energy
that
you know you it better overcome your
your feeling of risk
i don't think
that you necessarily if you're going to
start a company should do it at the
start of your career i think there's a
lot to be said for working for a company
learning how they do things you know if
you're young it's hard to go lease
premises they they made that hard for me
you couldn't rent a car uh when you were
under 25 at the time so i was always
taking taxis to go see customers
and
the
people with you know people say we're
going to go have a discussion in the bar
well i can go to the bar
[Applause]
and
but you know that's fun because i'll
tell you when people are first skeptical
and they go this kid doesn't know
anything
then when you show them you've really
got a good product and you know
something they actually tend to go
overboard and they think whoa you know
they know a lot uh let's really do an
incredible amount with these people so
our youth at least in this country
was a huge asset for us once we reached
a certain threshold it is hard it's hard
to hire old older people um
because they'll be a little bit
conservative about whether they should
come and take the risk and
it took three or four years before we
could go out into the normal sort of
employment pool but those those problems
that come with starting the firm you
better think of those as as part of the
the pleasure part of the the challenge
that that is part of the the excitement
throughout
our history we wake every day knowing
that in the business of technology
you have to think about what are you
missing what is the research or customer
feedback that you should be paying more
attention to and how do you keep that
pace of innovation very very high how do
you make sure you're hiring the very
best people and that kind of focus is
has helped drive us forward through all
the milestones the company has had
certainly the internet is is a great
example of that we had to
uh tear up our
our plans and and step back and say well
how do we how do we really embrace all
that's good about the internet and
recognize some of the shortcomings and
make sure we're leading the way in uh
reducing what what has held people away
from the internet computers when i was
young were super expensive and my friend
paul allen and i
actually snuck into places at the
university of washington where they had
computers that weren't being used at
night
and so we were fascinated by what the
computer could do
but very few people were getting
exposure we had to go
out of our way and we were lucky that we
did it all and so then when
the idea of moving the computer onto a
chip
that intel would make
and that would make the computer
literally millions of times cheaper
than the ones we were using so both more
powerful and available to people on a
personal level
then the idea of okay it would be very
different the software you needed the
way the industry would work we were
super lucky
to
be there when that was happening so what
did your family think did they say
there's something wrong with this young
man he wants to just do computers they
knew i was obsessed with computers that
i would skip athletics that i'd go in
overnight that i'd you know leave the
house sometimes
when they prefer i went go work at night
on these things and so it was kind of
considered a little strange
and the big moment was when i said
instead of going to part of my senior
year
that i wanted to go work
for company writing software so they
were great about allowing that to be my
hobby so you went to harvard and you
dropped out have you ever thought how
your life could be better off if you had
gotten your harvard degree
well i i'm a weird dropout because i
take college courses all the time i love
learning company courses and and things
so i love being a student and there were
smart people around and you know they
fed you and they gave you these nice
grades that made you feel smart uh so i
i feel it was unfortunate uh that i
didn't get to stay there but i don't
think i missed any knowledge because you
know whatever i needed to learn i would
i was still in a a learning mode so you
are here with your daughter who is 21
right
and you were 21 when you became a
billionaire is that right
almost yeah all right so around that age
you were you were like the youngest
person to become a billionaire is that
right for you
yeah in terms of my own earning it on my
own yeah right okay so which is the most
important thing yes so did you when you
were a kid did you
did you care about money or you just
cared about technology and that's it
just happened
uh mostly i love software
uh i do remember at the private school i
went to there were other kids whose
families were better off like they had a
porsche or something but it wasn't that
that big of a deal my thing was that i
just loved doing software i loved hiring
people and i was stunned when it ended
up being so valuable
really yeah
that surprised you yeah because i always
had to be careful
that we wouldn't hire too many people i
was always worried because i was people
who worked for me were older than me and
they had kids and i always thought what
if we don't get paid will i be able to
meet the payroll so i was always very
conservative
about the finances and then when we did
go
public
was i
uh
30 by then
then i was kind of stunned at what it
multiplied out to education
is essentially a social construct
it's not that the universities have
secret knowledge that only they have
available uh
you know i took these numbers won't make
any sense anymore but the hardest
freshman math class was called math 55
uh
i assume it's not called that anymore uh
but it was it was a group
[Laughter]
of uh as a group of 80 people whose
personal positioning was they were the
best person at math that they had ever
met so there were 79 frauds uh
one
person who really was the the best at
math i ended up the guy who came in
first in the class is a lawyer in new
york now uh the guy who came in second
as a professor of chaos theory of
princeton uh and then i came in third
so i knew okay math geez uh that's
interesting anyway
uh
i didn't take physics uh 55
but i read the feynman book and so
if you're motivated
seriously you don't have to take a
course the feynman book if you're
hardcore just read the finding book do
the problems you want to learn to do
software read the art of computer
programming good luck doing the problems
but uh you know anyone that's rated 30
or harder is like super hard to do
and so
a mooc in a sense
doesn't change what counts
uh you know it's always been in the
textbook but the percentage of students
who just buy textbooks and and read them
and know the subject is vanishingly
small you kind of have to have this
thing where a bunch of kids all come at
the same time
uh and you know if you don't study
you're going to get a bad grade and your
parents may not like that uh
you have to create all these social
things
in order for people to get into this
mode of hyper concentrating
and actually understanding why should i
concentrate you know if i'm a high
school student they put x's and y's up
on the board
how does that relate to my life now if
you understood that being good at math
lets you get a good job travel the world
you might say okay it does relate to me
but that's a very
indirect thing and the kind of
discipline
to care about that
uh to concentrate that's what's missing
and so moocs to the degree that it's
easier to take a mooc than it is to read
a textbook yeah that's nice it's a
little bit interactive there's a video
that's partly why i like the learning
company like all their economics there's
a guy named timothy taylor who has five
courses on economics i super recommend
uh
and you learn to like him and his way of
explaining things so a mooc is a
slightly more digestible form
of learning but it doesn't take
particularly for somebody at a young age
it in no way changes this question of
why should people
uh engage in that learning and how do
you create the environment and the sense
of achievement and the sense of
capability that sitting in there and you
know looking at x's and y's and
manipulating them uh seems like a smart
thing to do let's say you're
interviewing for a junior engineer
position at microsoft sitting in a
boardroom or on video call in 2020 why
should we hire you you should look at
the code that i've written you know i'm
kind of crazy i write software programs
way beyond any classes that i've taken
and think i've gotten better over time
so take a look at how ambitious i've
been there i do think i can work well
with people i might criticize their code
a little harshly but overall i like to
be on a team i like ambitious goals i
like thinking through how we can
anticipate the future software is cool
and i want to be involved how would you
define your strengths and your
weaknesses how you can you know
incorporate those into a team kind of
aspect well i'm not somebody who knows a
lot about marketing you know i wouldn't
enjoy being a salesman for a position
where you're actually creating the
products and thinking through what those
features should be i'm fascinated by
that i've followed the history of the
industry read about
the mistakes that have been made so
product definition product creation very
strong if you have a team
that understands the
customers the sales the marketing i'm
not going to bring that but i i would
enjoy working with them when you have a
tragedy like this pandemic there is
always the possibility you're going to
narrow your
community that you care about you're
going to think about yourself your
family not the whole country including
those who've been been somewhat left
behind likewise there's a risk looking
at africa and other developing countries
and saying no we need to help them out
because difficulties there of not enough
food are really extreme and small
amounts of the budget less than one
percent can help them out likewise you
don't want to just think about the here
and now you also want to think about the
future after all the government failed
us by not anticipating this pandemic
there were voices like mine in
ted talk and other venues that kind of
said hey get ready we don't know when
but it's coming sadly
that didn't happen another thing we
trust government to get us ready for is
climate change that's coming and it
won't be as easy as creating a vaccine
to solve it and so right now terms of
people's sympathy
being broad you know being willing to
address other problems even though
they're not here right now i am actually
seeing a lot of positive voices people
saying make sure the recovery is a green
recovery europe has done a lot on that
and so
and actually the dialogue in politics
about you know does climate change
matter is stronger today than it's ever
been so this closing in and only
worrying about the short term i'm not
seeing that
of course your audience which is very
young
will be the key to saying
let's not just look at this short term
let's start the investments that deal
with inequities let's start the
investments that can make sure climate
change doesn't come in and
have even more tragic results than this
pandemic does young people
thinking about policies getting involved
i think i'm seeing an uptick i hope
that's sustained because they're you
know they're the ones who will really do
the innovative work
if you want more inspiration morning
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it it's right there next to me go
click it there continue to believe and
i'll see you there